[Music]
let's talk about something that all
america is excited about arrested
development coming back
you happy about this
i'm ecstatic i mean
yes i am ecstatic
it's been it's been about seven years of
of uh you know
huffington post uh headlines like are
they gonna make the arrested development
movie i'm like uh but listen man people
on the street probably saying what are
you gonna make a lot a lot of people in
the street um i uh which has been which
is great i'm so excited that people are
still into it uh you know i i actually
had the opportunity to meet bruce
springsteen and he asked me about it and
i was like buddy uh listen i don't know
what what can i what can i say boss
we're just trying to
we're doing our best i did not call him
the boss by the way
that was an incredible name drop you
just did right there
oh i get it oh i get it cause you don't
know him yeah no he's um
good guy salt of the earth oh are you
kidding yeah
he's at my house this weekend um
but uh no we're really excited we're
making this arrest development uh um um
sort of mini series if you will and and
i think that i can say it's a
i don't want to do giveaway too much i
don't want this to be too much of a
spoiler alert but let me put it this way
that
there are
a few people
on this stage tonight who are a part of
it
and i think we know who we are
and a few a few means more than two yeah
yeah and less than four right
and it's it's us i know i know
uh jason bateman you happy to be working
with your old pal jason bateman again
i love jason he's great to work with i
tell you i always if there were a
premium to be paid on bad ideas i'd want
drilling rights to his head
what's the dickiest thing i've ever
heard
how is that no i love them
[Laughter]
no no it's great we're having such a
good time uh uh being back together and
and all of us working together and and
uh it's been uh it it was it's been six
seven years and we just all kind of
picked up right where we left off so
we're excited yeah it's super exciting
and you and bateman have a company
together is it what is it called dum-dum
it's called dum-dum
uh
and uh we do we're
we do really good stuff
um what do you do you do uh you have an
office you guys i don't know
i don't really know
you haven't we we have a you have an
office
together we have an office uh jason i
have this company dumb dumb we're kind
of like an online content company and we
work with brands and stuff and we have
an office that i never go to except
and jason loves going to the office he
goes in there and takes lunch meetings
and stuff and he's very uh industrious
about it all and so one day before i
knew he was in there i i had somebody
put in a pho our desks face each other
yeah and um and then i had somebody put
something in our office right behind my
desk that he has to look at all day i
think i think you brought a picture of
this this is behind her this is
what a great idea